a final vote tally from the floor of the
Senate related to the second article of
impeachment that Donald Trump was faced
up and 53 senators voting to acquit
Donald Trump finding him not guilty
let's see if we can just take a listen
United States guilty as charged
53 senators have pronounced him not
guilty as charged
two-thirds of the Senators present not
having pronounced him guilty
the senator judges that respondent
Donald John Trump President of the
United States is not guilty as charged
in the second article of impeachment
the presiding officer directs judgment
to be entered in accordance with the
judgment of the Senate as follows the
Senate having tried Donald John Trump
President of the United States upon two
articles of impeachment exhibited
against him by the House of
Representatives and two-thirds of the
Senators present not having found him
guilty of the charges contained therein
it is therefore ordered and adjudged
that the said Donald John Trump be and
he is hereby acquitted of the charges in
said articles